Remember that The David Pakman Show primarily
depends on folks like you grabbing a membership
at join Pacman dot com coupon code.
Good, only until tomorrow, Election Day.
20-20 now saves you 66 percent, two zero two zero.
Now at join Pacman dot com. If you were wondering
whether Donald Trump would encourage violence
after the election, you don't have to wait
until after the election because Donald Trump is
already encouraging and praising violence done by
his supporters over the weekend in Texas, a group
of truck driving flag-Waving, Trump supporters
surrounded a Joe Biden campaign bus. Joe Biden
was not on this bus at the time. And there
was even a sideswipe incident where one is the
one of these Trump trucks sideswiped a vehicle
that was following the bus driven by Biden
campaign staff. This is a hit and run. I mean,
this is this is violence. This is an attack. And
it led to the Biden campaign actually canceling
events in Texas because of security concerns.
Now, of course, anybody in favor of law and order
would denounce this, right? Not so far. In fact,
they've been praising it. Donald Trump tweeted
video of the incident with the message. I
love Texas during one of his dozen Korona
rallies over the weekend, said doing this to
the Biden bus was a hot thing. Take a look.
Did anybody see the picture of that crazy
bus driving down the highway surrounded by,
like hundreds of cars in their
own truck, flags all over?
It's like a hot. It's like a hot thing. See,
that's really number one trending. You know, they
won't put that. That's number one. They come up
with number one trending. It's it's not a trend.
It's whenever they want to do
this is really playing with fire.
His gun toting, flag waving supporters
are just waiting there. What was the term
standing by, so to speak, to go absolutely insane
with the violence on Trump? Say so. And here is
Donald Trump saying this is hot. Then Trump at one
of his rallies. This was last night in Opa Locka,
Florida, or Upper Loka. I'm
not sure how it's pronounced,
glorifying it and bringing up.
And Tifa, they had the thing with these
really I like very good people. They were riding
along the highway and you had sloppy Joes Bush.
So they escorted the bus and
the radical left said, oh,
what a horrible thing that is to escort the bus.
They don't tell you about it in Tifa, they go
around burning down your cities.
Democrat run only Democrat.
They don't talk about that boppin
people over the head killing people.
Fox News, of course, typically all about law
abiding, celebrating it, dismissing it. Here
is that lunatic Fox News. Judge Jeanine Pirro
saying this was Americans taking the election
into their own hands with vehicular crimes.
This was during an interview with Newt Gingrich
during a fascinating experience, though,
these spontaneous parades and boat parades
and organized get togethers not done by the
campaign, just people who are so energized.
They got to do something. So they're
out there doing it every single day.
Well, it is it is stunning. And what's what's even
more stunning is what was just trending, and that
is there is a Biton bust and it's surrounded by
pickup trucks on a highway, all with Trump signs.
I mean, it is ordinary Americans just taking this
election into their own hands and getting out
there and being real clear on what they stand for.
What is it they stand for? Because it seems to me
they stand for violence, vehicular crimes, not
counting votes, but stealing them, intimidating
people at polling places. That's what I see them
standing for based on their actions. This is a
call to violence. And I consider that attack on
the highway violence messing around on highways is
no joke. It puts lives at risk. This is violence.
And we have to remember what we are voting
against here. What we have to stop here. It's an
emergency. But both sides do this, right. I mean,
back in 2012, Obama supporters were driving
around in convoys with guns and Obama flags,
violently attacking people, sideswiping vehicles,
showing up armed put. A homeowner said, wait, when
that didn't happen. No, that didn't happen. And if
it did happen, we would know because it would be
24/7 on Fox News and Rush Limbaugh and all over
the place. And here, instead of denouncing it,
the Fox hosts and Trump himself are praising it.
And I hate to do this, but we have to go back to
it. And whatever, you know, after the results,
after we have the results, Wednesday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, I'm going to come
back to this. Up 40 percent of voters at least
think that this authoritarian wannabe dictator is
doing a good enough job to get himself reelected.
This is political terrorism. And 40 percent of
the country is either praising it or saying it's
not bad enough that they're going to retract their
vote for Donald Trump. That says something really
embarrassing and disturbing and disgusting
and alarming about the state of culture and
education in the United States. I know that
in the last 24 hours before the election,
the number one thing is not how the hell do we
fix education and culture in this country so
that someone like Trump could never do what he
has been able to do. It's a bigger question than
for the last 24 hours. But it's disturbing
to think about and it's something we will
have to deal with regardless of the results of
tomorrow's election. And I will go back to it.